the first four days of call of duty  world war ii's private beta have come  and gone  and we can't help but to look back at  some of our most memorable moments  from triple kills to various kill  streaks and beyond  we are looking forward to the private  beta's return on both  playstation and xbox one later this week  for those of you that had the chance to  play early this past weekend  what was the highlight of your beta  experience did any particular weapon or  perk help you dominate the battlefield  and for more cod world war 2 news  updates and gameplay  consider hitting the subscribe button  thanks for watching  when in the fight  call the target  five  recon flight concluded  strafing run inbound  that gold  oh  over there smoothly  oh  oh  mark the zone  [Music]  position confirmed  fighter aircraft ready on first traffic  he's moving day is ours